el médico puede realizar una
gastrostomía endoscópica percutánea o pg
para insertar un tubo de alimentación en
el estómago
si usted no puede alimentarse por la
boca durante un periodo prolongado la
digestión de alimentos comienza en la
boca cuando ingiere alimentos éstos son
empujados hacia el esófago un tubo
muscular que lleva los alimentos al
estómago donde se digieren
desde el estómago los alimentos pasan al
intestino delgado donde continúa la
digestión y los nutrientes son
absorbidos por el torrente sanguíneo es
posible que el médico le solicite un
tubo de alimentación
pg si usted no puede ingerir digerir o
absorber alimentos debido a cáncer
esofágico cirugía oral o accidente
cardiovascular cirugía mayor traumatismo
quemaduras o anorexia inflamación del
páncreas o radioterapia o enfermedad
intestinal inflamatoria que afecta al
intestino delgado
antes del procedimiento recibirá un
sedante intravenoso que lo ayudará a
relajarse se le administrara anestesia
local en la zona del abdomen donde se
ubicará el tubo p eje el procedimiento
de colocación de p&g más comúnmente
utilizado es el método de empuje durante
este procedimiento
el médico insertará un endoscopio con
linterna a través de la boca lo
deslizará por el esófago y hacia el
interior del estómago una cámara adjunta
al endoscopio producirá imágenes del
interior del estómago las que serán
visualizadas en un monitor de vídeo
luego el médico insertará una aguja a
través de la piel en el estómago donde
se colocará el tubo pg mientras hace eso
el médico utilizará el endoscopio para
ubicar el extremo de la aguja dentro del
estómago y encerrarla con una malla de
alambre luego pasar a un cable delgado a
través de esa aguja hacia el interior
del estómago adjuntará el endoscopio al
cable y tirará el endoscopio y el cable
hacia fuera de la boca en ese momento un
alambre delgado irá ingresando por la
parte delantera del abdomen hacia el
interior del estómago y continuará
subiendo hacia la boca
el médico adjuntará el tubo de
alimentación pg al cable afuera de la
boca
tirando suavemente del otro extremo del
cable el médico retirará el tubo a
través de la boca el esófago y el
estómago
continuará tirando hasta que la punta
del tubo salga por las incisiones del
estómago y abdomen
un tope suave y redondo adjunto a la
parte del tubo que queda adentro del
estómago lo asegurará en el lugar la
parte exterior del tubo también será
asegurada con un tope y una gasa estéril
será colocada alrededor del lugar de la
incisión en el método de empuje
alternativo el médico comenzará del
mismo modo utilizando un endoscopio para
orientar el cable a través de la pared
abdominal hacia el interior del estómago
sin embargo en lugar de tirar el tubo pg
a través de la boca el médico lo
empujará directamente hacia el interior
del estómago sobre el cable luego del
procedimiento
usted continuará recibiendo los líquidos
de manera intravenosa durante uno o dos
días una vez que se comprueba que el
tracto digestivo está funcionando
recibirá líquidos claros a través del
tubo pg si tolera los líquidos claros
recibirá una fórmula de alimentación a
través del tubo pg